can I look inside and say okay what was
the genesis for me who inspired me to
get to this point you know when I had
faced adversity and I look at it as a
challenge or an opportunity where did
that come from
who would I learned that from and that's
what this film is really about it is
about a kid somewhere somewhere seeing
the film and being inspired by the film
to be able to have the muses of his own
that's really what it's about
what is this kobe process you'll pick up
the phone you'll call people who are
leaders in industry and you just pick
their brain exactly this is that a
minute you know not just cold call
people absolutely a cold call people and
just pick their brain about stuff and
you know I'm some of the questions that
I ask they'll seem really really simple
and stupid quite honestly for them but
if I don't know you know I don't know I
have to ask and so I'll just do that
just ask questions and I want to learn
more about how they build their business
value run their companies and how they
see the world and so who are some of the
people that you pick up the phone and
call hello I started to just start in a
Nike family I got cold call Mark Parker
all the time
johnny is Dan Wyden Oprah Winfrey
recently Arianna Huffington and this
list goes on and on and on I know Hilary
Swank it just goes on take Johnny I've
yeah you guys have what just uh you have
a conversation and yeah well I want to
know
he's Ashley unique and what he does why
how how does he view product how does he
view the process of designing product
how does he know that he has the product
exactly where he wants it to be how do
you know those things you know how does
he seeing the world differently and
everybody else who's manufacturing
Hardware because there's something going
on from the moment that he sees
something to when it goes into its brain
his brain that's that's that's a
different process
and other designers I'm curious to know
what that is and you went to Apple today
you spent some time there
yeah went up to Apple spent the day
there talking with Johnny and it's kind
of picking his brain about product
things like that and what makes them who
they are why very very curious about
that and understanding that and I think
once you have passionate thing that
you're passionate about now you can look
at other people or other entities or
other things or works of art you can
draw things from that to help you be
better at what you do by looking for
those common denominators Johnny wanted
to know how do I prepare how do I
prepare how do I study how do I view the
game how do you build your game and my
response is much like the way he builds
products and you think sequentially oh
yeah you look at this the end result of
what you want to create but in order to
create that there's so many other little
things that go into this massive entity
that or device it's no different than
building my basketball you start with
where you want your game to be what
would make your game most unstoppable or
hard to deal with and now you work
backwards from there and you start
building it one piece at a time
one move at a time one counter so
there's a lot of similarities there
we've got this business Kobe Inc and you
made an investment in body armor the
sports drink are there more investments
coming well it's more building out the
internal structure and so I don't know
we haven't made any formal announcement
I'm sure we won't
Andrea Fairchild wired was recently at
Gatorade is now coming and helping me
build Kobe into writing kobe incan which
is cranking away everyday building out
the internal structure with the
companies to be in how can we
communicate the culture internally where
are we going you know building out that
model that plan and so that's really
what we're focused on stuff like yeah I
mean you need a headquarters you need to
I assume you need to hire people all
those things when you're starting up a
business right but you know you we also
want to get too far ahead of us I like
you know andrew is the one that really
keeps things lined up and dotted you
know I have this idea and this vision of
where I like us to go and now it's
important for us to go one step at a
time
not get too far head could you maybe
want to put the marketing skills you've
learned to work for others be a
marketing advisor maybe even to other
athletes yeah maybe I mean but it's it's
for me doing that it seems like I should
really just do that for free cuz what
I'm gonna tell him is be yourself
that's it bu bu there's no gimmick
there's no you don't have to contrive
anything who are you where are you today
what is your story where does that come
from right and then all you're doing is
not communicating the stories of the
public I mean I'm sure you've learned a
lot about that in the context of all the
endorsement deals you've had through
your career some of them are amazing
some of them may be less so I mean what
what what have you learned from going
through that process the endorsement
process yeah well you've heard a lot you
I've seen so many different sides of
that spectrum you know those who are the
best in the world at doing it
nay maybe not so and you see how they
operate see how they think culturally
other different you know how to
communicate whether they pride
themselves on companies that have
complete focus others that lose lose
focus and windup trying to regain it and
you know I've learned a lot just through
osmosis really you know being 18 17
years old and starting that journey what
was your reaction to LeBron James going
back to Cleveland is that do you think
important for the league yeah well you
know I think it depends how you fight
how you shape the story right I mean
it's like it's how you stayed in Miami
there's a great story that you can mold
and frame around that right and go to
Cleveland's way as you come on you know
and so it really just depends on with
his personal truth is and I think he
communicated his truth extremely well
and why you decided to go to Cleveland
and that's what you have to stick to and
you know for me it was just very
fortunate to be with an organization and
with the owner and and now is Jimmy and
Jeanie or just world-class man and they
pride themselves on taking care of their
athletes and trying to build
championship teams